geht ja nicht nur sozusagen um
kriminalität sondern um dominanz dieser
familien die ja nichts akzeptieren hin
deutschland das ist ja sozusagen das
geschäftsmodell von denen wie sehr
lassen sie sich aktuell als zuständiger
politiker von denen auf der nase
rumtanzen das lassen wir nicht mehr zu
wir gehen energisch dagegen voran stehen
diesen kriminellen überall dort auf den
füßen wo es ihm wehtut vor allen dingen
auch beim geld aber auch
niedrigschwellig das fängt beim parken
der zweiten reihe an das fängt an bei
brandschutz verstößen in shisha bars das
geht über drogenhandel hinweg bis hin zu
schwerstkriminalität und wir haben uns
entschieden
wir greifen überall ein und zwar
behörden übergreifend wir arbeiten eng
zusammen auf bundesland übergreifend und
insofern wir haben den kampf aufgenommen
wir werden ihn auch gewinnen also ich
habe etwas gegen die verzwergung von
deutschland wir sind das viertstärkste
wirtschaftsland ärger wenn wir wollen
dann können wir auch aber gemessen
entschlossen handeln